dans les rues de rennes en normandie au
futuroscope de poitiers ou encore à
lille les cotillons malgré les
restrictions
à paris des dizaines de milliers de
personnes venues du monde entier
[Applaudissements]
pas de feu d'artifice
alors chacun illumine 2022 comme il le
peut
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
dans les bars de la capitale la fête bat
son plein lorsque soudain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est presque deux heures et les
fêtards sont poussés dehors que ce soit
2 heures ou 5 heures du matin c'est la
même chose
là les gens qui s'amusent c'est
exactement la même chose c'est dommage
baptiste rentrez chez vous on n'aura pas
fait la fête comme il faut
[Musique]
bien s'en vient c'est tout seul
rendez vous demain c'est en fait moi ici
je crois
je veux déployés
[Musique]
dans ce hangar 1500 personnes se
déhanche sur de la musique techno en ces
temps de restrictions sanitaires la fête
avait pourtant été interdite par la
préfecture de l'yonne le pays entier
subit la cinquième vague de covin de
plein fouet mais pour beaucoup ici la
coupe est pleine la cnops a fait plus de
mordant en un an quelques vides et
pourtant pas on n'arrête pas le tabac
[Musique]
ah ah
quoique bon
à la queue leu leu
à la gueule
et demain après midi le premier ministre
jean castex réunira dix de ses ministres
pour préparer la continuité des services
publics essentiels hôpitaux écoles
administrations et transports en commun
notamment pour faire le point sur
l'impact du vieux riant au maquereau
alors ça c'est le rôle rigolo voilà
là où nous aurions pu tout reporter nous
n'avons jamais renoncé à notre ambition
collective le travail avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage le contrat
d'engagement jeunes qui sera mise en
oeuvre au début du mois de mars prochain
le pouvoir d'achat avec l'indemnité
inflation le chèque énergie
l'augmentation des salaires des
fonctionnaires les plus modestes
l'urgence écologique et climatique avec
le renouvellement de notre parc
automobile
un petit bonhomme en mousse
oh vous voyez que j'ai perdu des
centimètres à l'égout et l'emballage est
plus de chaussures on envoie les pistes
en l'air
la tête ce matin c'est la première
émission de l'année on avait envie de
vous faire ce plaisir rien que ces
dernières semaines et dans les prochains
mois des décisions dont on parlait
parfois depuis des décennies que je
viens à la cavalcade ici d'essayer de
rassembler ont été prises et seront
prises qui changeront la vie
la france malgré les épreuves et donc
plus forte aujourd'hui qu'il y a deux
ans la nostalgie pour une société c'est
la tendance à embellir le passé on
trouve ça chez les grecs chez les
romains au moyen-age la renaissance le
sait une tendance naturelle la cinquième
vague de covin 19 sera peut-être la
dernière
dans un entretien au journal du dimanche
olivier verront se montre plutôt
optimiste
selon le ministre de la santé la forte
contagiosité de micron pourrait aboutir
à une certaine immunité collective
bonjour je vois les entends jour bonjour
princesse
comment vivez-vous votre mort mais le
président suivait pas la mort cuttat
grand souci je veux plus vivre avril
1926 un écrivain américain décide de
créer une revue dans laquelle il
publiera des textes de prophétie
scientifique dit il est comme une guerre
satisfait de ce terme il va en créer un
autre qui fera littéralement fortune
science fiction
j'ai envie de gambader dans la vie
en bas
très heureux de vous avoir fait quelque
chose mais là je n'ai rarement j'ai
rarement le fait souffrir
non je peux pas faire ça ricane jean
slim je pense que je peux faire ça
kenshin frame une en
faut peu pour être débat il en faut peu
pour être heureux il faut un kit
[Musique]
membre du conseil supérieur j'ai besoin
de votre aide
comment pouvons-nous td mon enfant pour
faire sortir les mauvaises énergies par
ma gorge
une séance quotidienne qui n'étonne plus
ses assistants
or vous êtes d'où de paris paris paris
que paris même 20e et si le 2 1
c'est le 21e
rien rires
vous ne pouviez pas ne pas faire de
musique à un moment dans votre vie
c'était impossible oui oui je suis une
jeune mon papa jouer de la musique
jouait du piano
voix 6 votre père était un grand
scénariste way notamment de thierry le
luron bien sûr ça annonc é été plutôt
tiré la frontière et la faune
on a droit
total trajectoire n'était ces partis
politiques oui fort la vague à la la la
la je suis à la faute est lâché et s'est
fait mal il s'est fait mal
[Rires]
cagnina vous voulez vous maintenant
envoyer des décharges électriques
au
t1 10 mille ha ha ha ha
hahaha
or
merci du ha pour ma part
quelle que soit ma place et des
circonstances
je continuerai à vous servir
et de la france notre patrie
nul ne saura déracinés mon coeur
mon
amour bonheur santé on vous aime
faites de bonheur et de plaisir bien sûr
mais liz allaire
et le bonheur est plein de santé
otto dix bonnes années 2022
quand mais vous en avez duff la 2 c'est
bon ça julie
de oui c'est bon ça suffit et c'est le
troisième dans mes deux seins suffit
c'était trois semaines non ça va aller
on va passer à la suite parce que il
faut que je rende maintenant c'est
minute allait oser pêche